des robes légères dans les parcs au
bikini sur les plages
une seule obsession cet été traqué le
moindre poils disgracieux les femmes
dépensent en moyenne 500 euros par an
pour se faire épiler et pour avoir la
police et net à chacune sa méthode
ouais moi ces rasoirs ou crème
dépilatoire l'épilation à la cire puis
accord avec truc franchement ça me calme
où c'est ce que je préfère savoir
souffrir pour être belle simplement si
les femmes sont encore 30% à se raser
les jambes le bon vieux rasoirs a
maintenant du souci à se faire
des grandes surfaces aux instituts de
beauté tout le monde sauf sur la phobie
du poil quelles sont les dernières
tendances peut-on se débarrasser
définitivement de ses poils qui nous
empoisonnent la vie et qui sont ceux qui
s'enrichissent grâce au poil cette
semaine vous allez connaître tous les
petits secrets pour avoir des jambes de
rêve
cette drôle de tambouille
c'est en fait la dernière tendance pour
se faire épiler samira est en train de
préparer de la cire orientale et
franchement ce n'est pas vraiment
sorcier à la base cimetière pour les
pauvres
hier c'est une cire en fait y'a que de
l'eau sucrée un petit rang une recette
pas cher à fabriquer vieille comme le
monde et qui pourtant est maintenant
synonyme de luxe et de raffinement dans
les instituts de beauté haut de gamme
dans cet établissement l'épilation coûte
50 euros en moyenne deux heures de
cuisson plus tard la mixture de samira y
prennent goût
c'est cette espèce de caramels mous qui
va réussir à arracher les poils jusqu'à
la racine
à condition bien sûr d'avoir le coup de
main
samira elle tient ça de sa grand mère
marocaine
donc c'est une super cyr parce qu'en
plus ça fait là poids super douce après
comme un gommage quoi puis c'est des
produits naturels donc ça serait bien ça
fait peut-être un peu mal la première
fois mais la cire orientale est
particulièrement appréciée pour
l'épilation des parties intimes pour
faire le maillot comme on dit c'est ce
que demandent de plus en plus les
clientes
enfin plutôt les maris des clientes bah
oui mais en fait il y appelle à
l'accueil je veux prendre rendez-vous
pour ma faim pour une épilation
intégrale mais intégral et la femme est
obligée de suivre parce que voilà son
mari n'aime pas les poils et bien dit
qu'il m pour les deux bras et le fameux
ticket de métro
ces 54 euros un sacré budget à l'année
rien d'étonnant donc une femme sur dix
seulement se fasse épiler en institut
pour démocratiser le concept certains se
sont lancés sur le marché du low cost
sans rendez-vous demi jambes aisselles
maillot tout est à 3 euros 80 il s'en
ouvre un peu partout en france
alors comment s'y prend-il pour casser
les prix nathalie est une
inconditionnelle depuis cinq ans elle a
définitivement mis au placard ses
rasoirs le cadre ce n'est pas vraiment
le palais des mille et une nuits la cire
elle est industriel et la séance ne dure
pas plus de dix minutes
le vrai truc c'est que pour bénéficier
de ces tarifs avantageux nathalie doit
payer un abonnement 9 euros 15 par mois
ça fidélise les clients mais pas
seulement
karl enseignes proposent toute une gamme
de soins de beauté des soins du visage
au massage amincissant en passant par la
pose de vernis à ongles c'est comme ça
qu'ils se rattrapent sur l'épilation pas
chaîne me faire épiler environ toutes
les trois semaines
mais je viens aussi pour me faire une
manucure hebdomadaire après plus de
vingt et un sont dues
de 4,5 celle qui s'est lancée dans
l'épilation premier prix c'est elle
sophie landre une ancienne chef
d'entreprise elle dirige aujourd'hui 63
boutique qui font en moyenne 35 mille
euros par mois c'est cinq fois plus
qu'un institut classique
sophie a simplement appliquer le modèle
économique des centres de bronzage qui
marche grâce aux abonnements donc 6ème
c'est pas cher pourquoi parce que nous
avons joué sur la quantité de la
clientèle par jour on a entre 20 30 40
cliente jour dans les autres instituts
c'est plutôt 10 cliente par jour
ses poils à la longue ça finit par
devenir une rente à vie
il y a pourtant un bon moyen pour s'en
débarrasser définitivement ici
l'esthéticienne s'appelle bruno bonjour
la deuxième bruno est médecin esthétique
avant il passait sa vie à éliminer les
petites rides à gonfler les lèvres ou
encore à faire disparaître la cellulite
depuis peu c'est pour se faire épiler
définitivement que les clients
deviennent ça représente même 60% de son
activité
donc on fait d'ennemis jambes
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on avait terminé
aisselles maillot c'est le troisième
semaine son troisième séance sur
l'ennemi jambes c'est pas pris le soleil
du tout depuis trois mois la machine à
éradiquer les poils pour toujours c'est
elle un laser très puissant et qui n'est
pas sans risque il faut même porter un
masque de soudeur durant les séances
pour éviter de se brûler la rétine et
aussi mettre une crème anesthésiante sur
les parties à épiler ils nous montrent
la zone de projection de
je le sentiment
pas de chance si vous êtes une vraie
blonde ou si vous êtes tous oublié
l'épilation laser
ça ne marche pas sur vous le laser vient
chauffer le poil noir foncé qui va être
engagé un peu comme un condensateur et
plus il va être
foncez pluie va et épais plus va
accumuler la chaleur et puis après il va
transférer cette cette chaleur autour de
lui vers les cellules responsables de sa
croissance
chaque année un million de séance laser
sont pratiqués en france un marché
juteux que se disputent dermatologues et
médecins esthétiques demi jambes
aisselles maillot
il faut dire que les tarifs c'est pas
donné 250 voire 300 euros pour 7 pour
cette cette prise en charge voilà par
ses parts par séance donc voila vous
arrivez un coût de 1500 euros mettons %
pour cinq séances
les tarifs sont libres alors renseignez
vous bien sûr les prix d'un cabinet à
l'autre les tarifs peuvent varier du
simple au triple au fait satisfait ou
remboursé
ça permet vraiment de gagner énormément
de temps et esthétiquement c'est
niall poil sous la peau la peau est
beaucoup plus douce vraiment c'est un
régal ne plus passer sa vie pendant des
heures dans sa salle de bains à s'épiler
c'est le rêve de toutes les femmes
aujourd'hui
depuis deux ans un homme a fait fortune
sur cette simple promesse et vincent
brucci était vétérinaire
finalement il est resté dans le poil
mais en commercialisant le dernier cri
de la technologie de l'épilation à
domicile
la machine à lumière pulsée là encore
lunettes de protection obligatoire la
lumière pulsée attaque le poil à sa
racine il finit par mourir au bout d'une
dizaine de séances
c'est dans cette petite usine de la
région parisienne qui vincent les
fabriquent
il emploie une vingtaine de personnes il
a fallu cinq ans de recherches à notre
géo trouvetou du poil pour réussir à
miniaturiser la technologie de la
lumière pulsée
question design son premier prototype ce
n'était pas vraiment une réussite
j'ai eu quatre boîtiers comme ça
l'applicateur était quasiment approchant
un peu moins un peuple si on le compare
on a quand même une ressemblance
par contre le boîtier était un petit peu
différent mais on avait déjà l'écran on
avait déjà toutes les fonctionnalités
retoquée par toutes les grandes marques
à qui il a proposé son invention il
décide de la vendre lui-même sur
internet
résultat qu'il en est écoulé dix mille à
1350 euros la machine faites le calcul
ça lui a rapporté plus de 13 millions
d'euros
un succès commercial pour lequel l'ex
veto a dû prendre de gros risques qu'on
a vendu géniaux ma clinique sarr fait de
l'argent qu'on a que j'ai m'a permis de
continuer ses développements fièrement
on avait pu dessous
pour payer les l'appartement qu'on avait
tant qu'on a déménagé la campagne avec
tous les enfants
maintenant qu'il a ouvert la voie les
grandes marques d'électroménager se
lancent aussi sur le créneau avec des
appareils deux à trois fois moins cher
mais ils vincent est déjà parti à la
conquête de nouveaux marchés
sa priorité aujourd'hui c'est
l'angleterre et ses habitantes pour le
moins coquette
le plus drôle c'est que l'homme
d'affaires ne s'est même pas parler
anglais
l'épilation n'a aucune frontière les
poils sont sont parmi nous toutes races
tous pays
il est important d'aller à la conquête
pour arriver éradiquer tous à ce jour là
yves vincent a rendez vous chez une
agence de communication les deux
attachées de presse ont une idée très
british faire la promo de son produit
par deux stars du petit écran là bas
sont deux présentatrices télé qui sont
très connus ici en angleterre et
flamands
signifiera je sais pas voilà les deux
présentatrices télé ça ferait du buzz y
vincent est même prêt à dépenser 200
mille euros dans son plan de
communication mais pour faire sa pub il
a sa petite idée sur qui serait la
meilleure ambassadrice de la marque
outre-manche chalach and love affair
d'avoir tabloïds avec sur la couverture
la reine d'angleterre utilisant le wii
one la reine d'angleterre qui s'épilent
et puis quoi encore
franchement à nous français ça nous
ferait belle jambe